Speaker 1: All right, let's take a little
bit of a visit to fantasy land today, Donald
Trump's former press secretary, Kayleigh McEnany,
appeared on Fox News last night.
And this is a really instructive clip in revisionist
history and how quickly the failed administration
is trying to completely rewrite the past.
And if you don't if you're not aware of it,
if you don't say no, we're not going to let
you do that, they will gaslight you into completely
forgetting about what went down for four years
before Joe Biden was sworn in as president
in January of this year, Kayleigh McEnany
appeared on Fox to talk about how chaotic
the Biden administration is.
The context is Afghanistan, as well as Joe
Biden's diminishing approval rating.
We've talked about the diminishing approval
rating with Trump.
Things were different, but typically presidents
come into office with higher approval ratings
and they sort of diminish over time.
And we've talked about the dynamics of why
Kaili says during Trump's presidency, you
didn't have crisis after crisis.
Things weren't chaotic, things were calm.
What?
And she's able somehow to say it with a straight
face.
Let's take a look at the clip.
Speaker 6: Right.
We are eight months into a Biden presidency.
Jesse, wrap your head around that.
We still have three years and four months
left.
Look, when President Trump was president,
you didn't see crisis after crisis.
You just didn't see it.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine going on national
TV and saying that with a straight face?
So, for starters, half a million dead from
covid under Trump, as if it's no big deal.
It's the flu.
Open everything, no masks.
It's a Democratic hoax.
And then, of course, I mean, I don't have
an hour, but the Ukraine scandal, the North
Korean failure, the migrant border crisis,
attacking reporters and the institution of
a free press using a Sharpie to change a hurricane
map merely to make himself look better, going
to Puerto Rico after a hurricane, not knowing
Puerto Ricans are Americans, and then tossing
rolls of paper towels like their basketballs,
telling people in his administration to slow
down testing because too much covid testing
is making him look bad, inciting a riot on
January 6th, claiming that an election was
stolen and trying to actually stay in power
despite the fact that he lost you.
I would need an hour to go through the full
list of crisis, a day scandal, a day Trump
presidency review.
Does Kaili think we slept through Trump's
entire presidency or that we have collective
amnesia?
And then also, hilariously or just horrifyingly
like this is just the bottom of the barrel.
Kayleigh McEnany actually says imagine if
Joe Biden had been in charge when the virus
hit.
Speaker 6: I shudder to think about what covid
would have been like under Joe Biden.
And we've seen Afghanistan blow up crime in
the streets, you name it all.
What would it have been like?
Because I was in the White House when it was
pretty scary times.
Speaker 1: So there is just so much there.
And, you know, first of all, it's interesting
how she admits it was scary.
It was scary times when covid hit the entire
time she was in the White House and Trump
was president, neither she nor Trump admitted
that it was scary times.
She's admitting it now in order to say it
would have been too scary for Joe Biden to
handle.
But at the time, it was this is all fine.
It'll be gone by April.
Freedom and liberty will be open by Easter,
15 cases will soon be zero.
It's like the flu on and on.
Now, though, it was so scary, Joe Biden never
could have handled it.
But most importantly, Trump's handling of
coronavirus was one of the worst in the world
by the numbers.
During that first year when Trump was in charge,
we scaled up our testing so slowly that we
were constantly behind the curve.
Trump wanted testing slowed down.
He wouldn't wear a mask.
He wouldn't tell people to wear masks.
He played coy with the whole freedom and liberty
thing and attacked the governors that were
actually taking the virus seriously and putting
in place all sorts of different measures.
And Kayleigh McEnany has the audacity to come
in now and say, imagine if Biden had been
president.
Well, we'd have had fewer dead.
If Joe Biden had been president, wouldn't
be zero.
Of course, the virus has ravaged most countries
to some degree, but we would have been far,
far better off.
And so it's important to prevent them from
rewriting history.
It's important not to allow them to tell us
a story that is completely divorced from reality.
And we must remember that the Trump covid
response was a historic failure.
Some might even say it was an historic failure.
It's more of a grammatical question than a
historical one, but we have to ensure that
it's not rewritten.
And unfortunately, you know, there's just
there's just a reality that political memories
are short even now when we're seeing Joe Biden's
of.
Approval rating diminish, at least in part
because of what has been a successful campaign
to discredit and attack Joe Biden's withdrawal
from Afghanistan, which I am completely in
favor of, and consider one of his major accomplishments,
getting us out of a 20 year quagmire in Afghanistan,
talked about it earlier and earlier this week.
So I won't go into it again.
Now, there there's the idea of, wow, what
could this really hurt Democrats in 2022?
I kind of think it won't be number one, because
it's not really the Democrats that are up
for reelection.
It's Joe Biden and because political memories
really are short.
So it's important to remember that.
But still, we shouldn't allow them to rewrite
history.
And, of course, Fox News, which that that's
one other thing actually, I think is important
to mention.
We've talked anecdotally over the last three
or four weeks.
Oh, look, FOX isn't doing as much anti VAX
propaganda anymore.
Fox News is sometimes telling the truth about
the safety of the vaccine or whatever for
the most part, and in particular the nighttime
shows, although it's on the daytime shows
as well, a FOX News is still hosting, promulgating
signal boosting and allowing really, really
aggressive propaganda, disinformation, misinformation
and the rewriting of history.
And last night's Kayleigh McEnany appearance
is just more more of the same